the countdown to the Iowa caucuses it is
on after endless campaigning and GOP
candidates crisscrossing their state
voters in Iowa will finally get their
say and it all starts in just 3 hours
from right now the caucus is already
shattering records but maybe not for the
reason we would want as Jessica and I
are finding out it is indeed freezing in
Iowa you have heard about this record
cold is hitting the Hawkeye State and it
could have an impact on the turnout but
the candidates hope it won't stop voters
from showing up tonight you can't sit
home if you're sick as a dog you say
darling I got to make it even if you
vote and then pass away it's worth it
Blizzard or not if the Ians have shown
up we have shown up as well and we will
lead this country in the same way so get
excited caucus opens at 7 we have an
opportunity tonight uh to really chart a
new course forward for this country has
nothing to do with anything but taking
our nation back you deserve to be proud
of your president you deserve to be
proud of your country you deserve to
have your children know what it's like
to love America Trump is is running for
his issues you know Haley's just doing
what the donors want uh I'm running on
your issues and your family's issues and
solely to turn this country around do
whatever you can to get them to come out
tonight and vote for me front runner
Donald Trump working his charm in the
Hawkeye State and delivering pizzas to
First Responders as part of his final
pitch Trump is looking for the biggest
blowout win in Iowa caucus history
tonight the candidates behind him are
banking on an upset and gaining major
momentum Nikki Haley Ronda sandis and VI
ramaswami all holding events today to
make their last minute pitches to voters
and president Trump just now put out a
statement on Truth social I want to read
it to you here he says that Nikki Haley
can never win in the general election
because she doesn't have Maga and never
will Ronda sanctimonious at least is
magal light the vake votes are wasted
should come to Trump make America great
again and Greg I'll go to you cuz he
used three exclamation points and you
are our exclamation point we wish you
were here Greg oh I wish I was is it
cold I hear it said the weather I hear
you know I it's a lot of breaking news
to deal with about you know the weather
may have an impact or it may not I think
we need to go wall to wall on the
weather I love how the media is doing
its job reporting that comment that
Trump made as straight news that he
hopes his V his supporters might die um
if you if you play the clip long you'll
hear the people laughing but the media
yeah but the media needs everybody to
set their hair on fire uh Trump doesn't
care if you die meanwhile I I don't know
if anybody saw this the NB NBC not
Infowars NBC is reporting that public
interest groups and lawmakers have
devising a plan to stop the military
from carrying out Trump's agenda that's
NBC that blew my mind uh isn't that a
coup uh to get the military on board to
subvert the C commander-in-chief and
again I'm reporting it because it was on
I'm reporting it I'm talking about it CU
it's on NBC look uh about today Trump
supporters are very loyal and they're
loyal for a reason uh for that previous
story you're watching a guy basically
risk everything for including his
business and I would say his life and
the more that Trump gets targeted the
deeper the Loyalty gets because people
who support him want to share that risks
but then there are people that are going
like look you know what uh it's 4-Hour
drive to an hour at the beach with Trump
because the Dems have created a a huge
destruction machine that will not just
Target Trump but everybody else so they
start to move towards DeSantis and Haley
because that's the that at least maybe
they won't be so hard on me you know if
if I support them um and then you have
VC which to V which is in many ways to
me Trump without the destruction machine
focused on it and that's not Trump's
fault but it is viv's
benefit that is yeah indeed and in fact
one thing that's pretty interesting
judge is how the issues have uh evolved
here so about six months ago by far the
number one issue the economy and that's
still up there but in the last six
months as the Border story has changed
that has now become the number one issue
here with the economy close behind you
know that's an interesting question and
I think that it really is a result of
people like Greg Abbott making sure that
the Border issue is one that doesn't
just affect the southern border but
affects all of us literally making every
state a border state and so to a certain
extent he gets credit or blame for that
I personally credit him but I want to
say one thing about the weather and Greg
talked about the weather I am so sick
and tired of people talking about the
weather I grew up in almyra New York I
don't know if you've ever heard of it
but it's in the snow belt I went to
school in Buffalo at the University of
Buffalo where it was always snowing look
these people are Patriot rots as long as
the roads are clear they're coming out
tonight they don't care that it's cold
Only We Care that it's cold okay so
enough about the weather now D santis
did uh something like 140 events he went
to every one of the 99 counties he
knocked literally on a 100,000 doors
they say and then you've got RIS Swami
who did 99 counties twice so then you
have Nikki Haley who's criticizing Ronda
santz for spending so much money and yet
here we are at the end where Nikki Haley
is dumping all of her money into the ads
so it'll be very interesting to see what
happens here tonight I believe that
Trump is going to win I think he's going
to win resoundingly and I think by the
way to those people who want to give so
much credit to Iowa the last time the
person who won Iowa won the election was
almost a quarter of a century ago in the
year 2000 so let's not make it like it's
the weather for you know all things uh
uh having to do with the presidential
election uh and finally let me just say
that uh I think that Nikki Haley to a
certain degree has reached her ceiling
because the fact that 43% of her voters
will actually vote for Biden tells me
she's got the Trump haters on her team
and that's not going to help her so much
with Republicans unless which you've got
our Democrats who are changing party
just to vote in the Iowa caucus it that
will be interesting all right Jesse
Waters let's hear from you I got to say
something about the weather okay great
jerk I was in Florida over the weekend
Dana it was 60 degrees 60 is that good
or bad I had I had a long sleeve shirt
on Dana I I barely
survived I expect a big win by Donald
Trump tonight and he has to run up the
score and the longer this primary goes
on his air of inevitability of
invincibility is punctured so he's
looking for a first round knockout
someone like a big candidate of aake and
Nikki de santis has to drop out in
January the longer this thing goes makes
New Hampshire tedious makes it more
expensive and the party just eventually
has to listen to the will of the voters
and unite and coales around one man one
front runner to make it more formable to
go after Joe
Biden they have a lot of money already
spent the disantis campaign if he
doesn't have a very strong second place
showing I don't see how he continues I
think the big headline is we'll see we
have no idea how that's going to shake
out then I'm hearing all these Democrats
are going to come out and caucus for
Nikki to make Mischief in the primary
but that doesn't make sense to me
because I was supposed to be under the
assumption that Donald Trump was the
person the Democrats wanted to be the
nominee because it was easier for
President Biden to be
so why wouldn't they be caucusing for
Donald Trump if that's the case so I
don't believe that at all um the V had
run a Flawless campaign the relationship
between his campaign and the magga base
had been really crisp and then he
stepped in it and use some words like
eliminate and demise the man has such a
brilliant vocabulary I'm confused about
why he'd say that it's not a big issue
he's still a great surrogate and he's
still in the running for a cabinet
position so I still don't see that at uh
really terminating his relationship with
the Trump base but Dana again uh Florida
was 60° I don't know how you guys are
handling it well I actually think that I
have not even been outside for a total
of five minutes in the last 48 hours I
we just you know we're well taken care
of in from the car into the warm uh
Jessica you're a Democrat watching this
Republican caucus here in Iowa tonight
how are Democrats looking at the
possibility of these Republicans whoever
it might be probably Trump right to go
after Biden the ABC poll came out today
Biden's numers now at 33% approval yeah
there's no doubt that Democrats are
nervous about the general election but
our expectation is that Donald Trump
will win tonight and the question is
just how big he has the potential to get
through the 50% threshold he'd be the
first person um in history to do that
and that definitely seems like a record
that he would like to smash and I think
that's why we've seen the shift to
attacking the ramaswami in the last
couple of days because V voters also
like Trump V himself likes Trump so if
he can get a couple of percentage points
off of aake then maybe he can get that
50% uh threshold and we'll be talking
about that for the rest of time um but
it really is tonight about that race for
number two Kent desantis's ground game
and I met this morning uh Governor Kim
Reynolds was here Bob Vander plats was
here they're both backing to santis he's
done the 99 counties but Nikki Haley is
all over the airwaves you can not turn
on the television without a Nikki Haley
ad um and she's doing really well in uh
the city centers which have been
snowplow and that will be the big
question about the weather which I know
you guys are also excited to to talk
about um her voters can pretty easily
get to the polls can Trump voters and D
santis voters to some degree make it to
the gyms or wherever they're going to
caucus this evening all right U stay
tuned for 20 more weather reports just
kidding okay the countdown to Iowa says
it's just getting started don't miss
special coverage it starts at 10 p.m.
Eastern with Martha and Brett but up
next team Obama is talking trash about
team Biden why they say the Biden
campaign doesn't have what you know have
its act together but they use a
different word hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else